the US always prided itself as having
the world's most formidable military
machine a standing force of nearly half
a million many stationed on bases in
far-flung parts of the globe do solemnly
swear or affirm he's always where but
now recruitment is at its lowest level
since the draft was abolished 50 years
ago and hardest hit is the Army if we
don't turn our recruiting situation
around I can't guarantee you that the
Army won't have to make some more
substantial potential for structure
reductions uh because we we've got to
make sure that our units for example
that are on the immediate response Force
are manned adequately so that they're
ready to go the secretary herself
appears in commercials aimed at
increasing recruitment but they appear
to have little impact in a market that's
been fragmented by increasing political
divide and bipartisan anger that
threatens to politicize the military
itself
many Republicans accuse the military
tree of in their phrase being woke
pointing to the renaming of bases named
after confederate Civil War leaders and
in particular the recent Pentagon
decision to pay for enlisted personnel
to travel out of those states that have
banned abortion
some Democrats in turn point to the
proportionately large number of veterans
and even serving Personnel who took part
in the attack on the capital in January
2021 so I think the biggest challenge
about the presence of domestic violent
extremism in the military isn't
necessarily the numbers because the
numbers are small but it's that it goes
counter to the oath of service and so
Americans see that as a real tension
point when it comes to
entrusting the military as an
organization compounding the recruitment
problem 25 percent of those who want to
enlist do not meet the required physical
or academic standards the military has
started what it calls a Future Soldier
Prep course to address this issue elite
units have been largely unaffected as
long waiting lists of qualified
Personnel to join Special Operations
units in every Branch but it's not the
experts who keep the military machine
running it's the cooks the drivers the
maintenance teams the ones who are
seldom noticed unless they are not there
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington